That's why I'm the
name
Takataka glasses aren't even ringed on the side of the person. I've
noticed that it's about as major as
Lolo.
[Music]
8 At first,
there was a cave scene in the game before this, which is the effect of the time hole, so
why is the North American continent stubbornly timed at the moment when the time hood hits, so it's a real thing  You know how dolphins grow and die, so
one more
thing, he went to see the gold while looking at the gold that the designer first made by hand
. Well, I wonder if the staff lacked Sanyo recognition.
It's
hard to get the reality that it doesn't come out because it's like an older brother because it's
made to the left and right weight, but it's difficult to make it after all
3 d scan
Well,
set the cheapest one
I took a picture of him because
I'm a little sorry that my staff is
buying it
. I
'm coming in because Ou is making it.
Yes, yes, I can see the thermo's legs here because I can't understand it. It was the same with
Sam's legs every time, so was the American family.
There is
blood here, so this is a hint, so please remember it for a moment.
That's why Stranding is this stranded now
Strand Why whales and dolphins are
lying on the shore, so the taste is the same, the cold is lying, the camera is getting closer,
they wake up and the world is visible.
I'm doing it graphically. The first and rare cuts.
Well, the series so far was originally from the old series
because there was a race, so I and the staff arranged it from there.  It was a task of adding,
but regarding the title of Best Landing this time,
I think that it will be the case if players who are playing games after zero start, but
what is the world view of Landic?  At
first
, I think it's a mysterious world view that I don't understand, but
we are the first.
Even when I started making it, I didn't really know what the world view of the best landing
should be, and if I was
really groping for it, I would like to carry it like building a world view of running
.  Hey, in a different sense. At
first, I put it on fashionably, so I thought I wouldn't put it together at all
.  I
understand, and then weapons will be made
. When I was carrying it, this kind of thing wouldn't come back, and it would crystallize. It
's the material of that house, but it's about to
hurt, so that soul will come out.  I've done it inside, but I've been watching it for a long time, so
I don't think there's anyone
who sees it.
It's a year, but the color order of the singer, etc. Let
's bend and bury
it. It's a game that connects with a rope in the same way as that, but there is a saying that it is tied up in a different sense.
Now that
money is in the wind
and
he's sandwiched, he's not hooded, so you can
feel what
the timehole will do here.  I'll show you the taste, but I
'm going to elucidate it scientifically.
At this time, there's that r Ernest Borg Nine
volume.
I haven't seen it
[laughs]
That's the strength I'm scared of, so it's the same with my
hobby grandmother, but
by adding the sci-fi element of sf, I'm not scared
.
As the game progresses, technology will come in. That's the equipment.
Shin-chan is good
at it, so it seems that the wisdom of humankind will solve the mystery by incorporating it with robotics or mechanical things
.
I think that scared person is okay, that Spillberg is already pretty scared
, so it seems that he will make it sf.
At first, it might be more like a suit. It seems like you can carry more luggage at first.
However, when you actually model and play the game with that, it's still
a little more familiar, so it's a little more like this.
I redesigned it into a suit that is more realistic than
it really is, and I have a low brain, such as adding elements from the so-called part.
I wanted it to be a color like blue, orange, green, etc., which is kind of hospitality, so I think that it is
not a weapon but a funeral,
but I
think that there are people who get the club as sci-fi.  For example, in a Western-style building,
I think it's strong to see that there's nothing from the dinner party and fighting from 10 o'clock, isn't it
?  It's okay for this child to solder,
no, I don't have a voice like this
anymore, I can see this guy who doesn't seem to be here.
It's no good with a farmer. It's
aging in an instant. It's like this when it's normally affected by orange
. It doesn't die, but
this is connected to bb, which
shows the distance and direction.  All of the moving fans should be with the boyfriend.
I'm playing the game. I've added a few more steps
in making it. It turns orange and rotates, and
finally the cut scene here is also fixed according to the game.
It seems that the adjustment is to make it a user friend when making it. At
first it was 3 steps, so I do not know the distance a little, so
I increased it more and changed the color.  Even
so, the number of joints will increase, so
stop the darkness program with a slightly heavier sound. At
first I expected a corner thumb-up at all, but I wanted to have that listening
expression, so I wanted to put in a girl, so when I
got out of the bt area  I'm happy with thumbs up, but I
didn't put it in the joint, so I'll do another one here with my house later.
I can't see it, so it
's a sense of smell and
touch with you. It's like a game tutorial, and
you're looking for something that
you can see.
This
modela people's movements change and they move away
, so I'm on the door right now, but I'm originally from another world,
so I'm going through it, so it's the same with the first ordinary Sam's luggage, but it was through.  However, it's
not strong, so I'll change it a little in the middle
.
It's a
skeleton that can be changed in the final. Well, this is a little like the mask of Higgs
. I'll choose Miyazu Gears from Egypt later.
Cut cm Enter in one and enter the game very smoothly. The camera of the game is
one of the operations of the error by yourself. Even if
you switch the mode
, it will be an adventure with your own camera by connecting to the year smoothly.
Stranding I'm talking about drinking
while showing information one by one on the screen
as much as possible, but after all that
Norman Reedus Matts Mikel Senlayer Now, the
speed of being a person comes out.  So
you can choose 2 cameras like a movie in France, and if you keep the camera pulled,
you'll want to see more Fanger, so why do you
want to go with one bottle and show the facial expressions to the actors?
Well, I
can't see it four times intentionally.
This expression is quite difficult, isn't it? I can't understand it unless I can see it at all.
If there are 10 people, there
are about 7 people.
Maybe it's about the same as the pros and cons of the game
.
It's understandable that you're listening to bt, but you're still listening
to someone in this world who doubles as a chinga.  It's common knowledge that bt can't be defeated
. This smoke is Mick at the incinerator after this. I'll do the same thing again.
This isn't the case because I'm wondering what happens when I'm caught by the. This is also outdoors. Is
n't this okay
?  Hey
, even though he was caught, a
hunter and a guy came out of Tar and were
taken away.
This is scary. I'll experience it later in the game.
First, let's see what happens in the cut scene.
What I'm trying to do is to make
it a boiler if I'm taken to a human who has lived my life as it is,
so I had to hit an iron
pile without killing it before that.  x By the
way, if you have a baby pot and it's a little shaped like a tool at a
temple, and you're wearing a golden mask, the tool will be at 10 o'clock at the temple
.
Because of that, Tar is
scared of the baby baby bb sound.
I can't move it because it doesn't come out
. It's a just modeling site for allergies. My
mother,
how much I noticed the major,
I entrusted bb and I'm about to die
I'm allergic to
allergies, but in the end the correct answer doesn't have allergies, but I
shed real tears.
This game connects the world alone, but
from the middle, someone like me  There are people all over the world,
but I can't see them. I
can't even doubt bt and humans.
I think I'm doing it, but
even if I enter the world of poetry with my parents and friends, I'm sure I'm still somewhere. Even if I
can't see it, why is that kind of connection? Life and death are inseparable.
I want you to understand that they are connected to each other.
Yeah, this game is afraid that whales and
meaties will rise from
the sea, but in the
first place, life was in the sea, wasn't
it?  We're up and
suicide
now, so the sea should be our starting point, but
why do we think it's the same as a sex city?
You don't have to be afraid, so why is it your hometown or your hometown
? That's the theme that you're sure to be connected
to
that
.  It's a stand, but it was quite difficult
. Let's get rid of the contradiction by being grabbed
by something. I'm a driver like this who can't commit suicide enough.
I want to cut it here. It's
attached here. That bb pod
reacts when
you hit it sony. This is the worst state of this. This is the worst state. This
is the best position of the camera here. This is also difficult.
I'm connected by this guy's Konoe garden student. It's a
giant,
isn't it? I thought I intentionally designed it because it doesn't have a body, but
it looks like a face.
That's why I
played it with a bag and played it with a bag. I saw a picture like
this, and because it was the best of those days, I was swaying, such as suicide, but at first I was fishing vertically and
connected from the top to the top, but this  If it's a bug,
I'm a cool sa guy, right? That's
right. Well, if you have a Yodoe face on your face, it's not that you're dead.
You can void out
8 by saying that you can do it. This is ah ah ah
. I made it slowly these days. It takes a very long time even if it is quite different
.
The script has been completed, so
I explained it in order, and
it felt like the details were being conveyed to him more and more.
-Is there a board or something, but after all the
details have not been released yet, so I explained it verbally
and I said that it was such a setting, but there
was also a part that I changed a little later.  Because
there is, I want you to feel how it is to connect the world and connect it because it is a game that connects and deposits a little closer to how to take the TV series,
but I think that you will feel various things while playing the game.  We have a lot of people all over the world
and think about what it means to connect with them. We want
our real people to bring back
the part of that connection to
their lives, and from there
everyone will act on their own.  I think it would be good if that happened
[Music]